le drame roumain telle une tragédie
antique l'unité d'action la chute d'un
dictateur
unité de temps à peine une semaine hier
soir le monde entier a vécu via la
télévision le dernier acte de cette
tragédie
le procès du tyran déchu et même si l'on
n'en connaissait la fin puisque la
veille l'annoncé de son exécution avait
été faite même si on savait que chaouchi
secoue mourait à la fin de ce procès les
images dégager une étrange émotions vous
avez été très nombreux à suivre ce
procès retransmis en direct par antenne
2 hier soir vers 23 heures et vous
l'avez certainement senti il y avait la
dimension humaine de l'événement
l'arrogance mais aussi une certaine
dignité du dictateur enfin ce procès
expéditif de chercher ce coup et sa
femme pose beaucoup de questions encore
non résolus hervé brusini récit et
analyse jeunes à s'y masser les
spectateurs 28ème aspect d'emblée tout
est dit chers téléspectateurs nous
allons vous présenter des aspects du
procès des inculpés ceausescu ce qui a
été donné à voir n'est donc qu'un
montage de différentes scènes
mais d'abord qui voyons nous les
chaouche et secoue bien sûr et un
militaire très obligeant un médecin
aussi au comportement clinique et son
assistant et le procès commence
vous êtes en face du tribunal du peuple
je ne reconnais aucune autorité si ce
n'est celle de la grande assemblée
nationale dit chercher secours mais
l'assemblée nationale a été dissoute
le nouveau système légal est différent
alors c'est un coup d'état l'ancien
hochet secours on vous juge selon la
nouvelle loi énoncées par le conseil du
front salut national et vous êtes priés
de vous mettre debout inculpé réponse
l'un constitution de l'état fait
autorité je cite la constitution et on
l'interrompt la constitution on la
connaît mieux que vous qu'il n'avait pas
respecté
je ne répondrai plus à aucune question
face à chaouchi secoue ses juges restent
invisibles et pourtant on pourrait
aisément les dénombrer regardez cet
homme porte le brassard du comité du
front de salut national
à gauche les mains d'un autre homme il
fume une cigarette et porte le costume
se serait donc peut-être un civil tous
ces gens sont debout
le montage ne respectent pas la
chronologie du procès au premier plan un
hommage et des cheveux blancs juste à
ses côtés celui là porte un pull-over
peut être un autre civil et à l'extrême
droite de l'écran un uniforme de l'armée
probablement l'un des deux avocats
tout au long du film ces images arrêtés
vont permettre d' occulter
l'identité des membres de la cour
laisser mourir les gens les enfants à
l'hôpital sans nourriture sans chauffage
sans lumière ça ne vous a pas surpris
tout ça je parle à l'inculpé nicolas
chaouch et ce coup au nom de quoi été
perpétré le génocide de timisoara
à toutes ces questions aucune réponse
et voilà pourquoi le peuple lutte pour
le pays et chercher ce coup car il veut
éliminer cette bande de traîtres
avec l'aide de l'étranger qui ont
organisé un coup d'état
et peu à peu nicolas ceausescu va
retrouver le ton les expressions les
gestes du dictateur qu'il fut à
plusieurs reprises et que la chaussée
scouts en train d'empêcher sa femme de
répondre aux questions des juges le
procureur va lui reprocher d'avoir vécu
essentiellement avec des étrangers lui
l'ardeur nationaliste et chaouch escou
s'esclaffe
l'avocat demande que l'on supprime la
peine de mort pour son client
un client qui regarde sa montre
impatience devant une parodie de procès
ou espoir car il sait qu'au dehors les
hommes de la securitate et se battent
encore pour lui je vous rappelle dit il
que lorsque j'allais dans les usines en
face des travailleurs ne continue en
plus dit l'avocat qui se fait procureur
c'est une décision de la justice
populaire roumaine brut chaises tout le
monde se lève on va délibérer c'est
épaulettes c'est un militaire retour de
la cour la sentence est définitif dit
l'avoir ceausescu a peut être alors
compris que la mort était vraiment
proche
alors comment ça se passe et comment en
commande chez squat il réagi après
bosser
pierre
il a pleuré ce soir à la télévision
s'était refusé de me reconnaître comme
jugé qu une autre était un traître
vous l'avez vue vrillée ce discours oui
mais le cribler perd de l'argent ne peut
se retenir de il essayé de courir et 7
et c'est dur pour lui de terminer je ne
peux pas tout se passait complètement
on a même filmé perdu le contrôle
pouvait plus obtenir
je suis tout ça je ne peux pas vous
c'est parce que c'est un vrai les
cheveux le sujet d'une action de
vengeance et de représailles militaires
c'était donc lui l'homme aux cheveux
blancs présents lors du procès il devait
en être l'un des procureurs
on avait vu à plusieurs reprises à la
télévision quelques jours auparavant